the MP Lloyd Russell morale has just
revealed that he has he is hiv-positive
lissa have listened in recent times what
was what Irma no disease is now seen as
a manageable condition yet the
information has not changed the
narrative which is still sadly framed in
those scare campaigns of the tombs of
the 1980s get so much of LGBT culture
also is marked by this specter of HIV
something that has led to an incredible
sense of fear about the disease and in
that hospital room and in the days of
weeks that followed I had to come to
terms with that fear myself I'm a hecho
v+ man but because I've been taking the
right medication for several years I am
what the NHS calls hiv-positive
undetectable that means not only can you
not detect HIV in my system so I don't
get sick it means that I can't transmit
HIV to someone else so as the virus lays
undetectable and dormant in my body my
medication ensures that the virus
doesn't reactivate doesn't progress and
can't be passed on that's why mr. Deputy
Speaker the NHS says undetectable equals
untranslatable UN AIDS highlights three
large studies conducted between 2007 and
2016 of HIV transmissions among
thousands of couples with one partner
being positive and the other negative in
those studies there was not a single
case of sexual transmission of HIV from
a positive undetectable person to a HIV
negative partner mr. Deputy Speaker it
is safer to have sex with someone who is
HIV positive undetectable than to have
sex with someone that doesn't know
status yeah because undetectable equals
untranslatable understanding that I was
unable to transmit HIV sexually has been
life-changing too I went from thinking
that I would never have a HIV negative
partner or that if I had sex with
someone I could pass it on to the
knowledge that I can live a normal life
and that any partner I have is totally
protected
so mr. Deputy Speaker I can't transmit
HIV to my sexual partner I have a
perfectly healthy life
so my announcement here today should go
totally unnoticed